caleb is with us in Birmingham hey Caleb
what's up hey Dave how you doing better
than I deserve man how can I help
well about three months ago I moved out
of an apartment I was paying $400 a
month later my grandfather actually
offered to let me buy a trailer and some
land from him
and three months ago I thought it was
really good idea we haven't signed any
paperwork or anything like that we're
gonna do that into October
I'm currently in baby step 2 I have
about $8,000 lifting my snowball are you
saying well I'm actually getting married
tomorrow
Oh congratulations how old are you about
27 okay and is little is the land
adjacent to his land it is part of his
land land in the trailer in Florida
sizzling yeah okay and man him rent well
no the thing is he had told us at first
that you know and me and my wife moved
in that we could live here you know
basically rent-free but he wanted to
sell it and he didn't want to go through
a bank and do it he just wanted to mean
him to sign papers and it was over a
five-year term though yeah me paying him
175 a month for five years and it being
paid for gotcha
and how much how much land it six acres
okay and what's the land worth well we
did an estimate an estimated for about
18 okay and what's the trailer were
about 3,000 probably okay all right and
so what's your long-term plan well no
one in my family's around a house your
grandfather lives in a trailer
my grandfather is lived in a trailer his
whole life okay and that's what I want
to do right now you want to you want to
get a house yeah eventually you know
tomorrow I'm getting man I'm actually
good makers hard listened to your show
and I got saved about a month ago
Wow
regulations me and the lady that I'm
with we've actually been as you college
hacking up for about three years and she
starting a job and she's actually
cashflow and we're gonna cashflow her
college okay so that's another thing
right now but I just don't know you know
I like the trailer the landed I grew up
on yeah okay let me let me walk you
through the downsides
okay there's downsides and there's
upsides upsides is this is real cheap I
will cost you a lot of money and you
like the land and it's an easy deal to
do with your grandpa okay although
that's an easy thing upside the upside
is the trailers not worth anything and
so you're not losing anything when it
goes down in value because trailers go
down in value they're like a car you
sleep in okay they go down in value and
so the upside is are gonna get a nice
piece of dirt that you like and you're
gonna have it paid for in a couple years
okay the downsides are that you are in
debt to a relative bad medicine all
kinds of potential for crap there okay
that you don't want another downside
this land is adjacent to his and he's
always going to have the sense that he
should stick his nose in what you're
doing with his land although it didn't
his land anymore in other words if you
wanted to sell it to somebody he might
get mad at you is that you don't want
that no okay
the other the last downside I hear is
you are trying to break a generational
thing on owning a house and you're
moving into that trailer gives a chance
that you get stuck in this generational
rut and you never get out yes okay so
the only way you do this is if you make
some kind of a commitment almost in
writing you and your new wife and you
put it in an envelope and you write a
letter to yourself that says self in
three years we're selling this stuff and
moving off of here if we're not building
a house on this and you talk to Grandpa
and you say grandpa I may sell this
whole thing someday and you got to be
okay with that if you're not ok with
that we don't need to do this deal right
now what would I do if I woke up in your
shoes
I probably would go find me a little
house in town and rent it and start my
life separate from this whole thing and
say tell your grandpa you appreciate it
and he appreciate his kindness but it's
not a good idea and I'm gonna just rent
something cheap and save my money and
buy me a house that's probably what I
would do because it's not got all the
family entanglements and all the
potential downsides I'm not gonna get
stuck in a rental house and I might get
stuck in the family tradition of a
trailer you following me yeah you want
to break the chains on this and it's not
say your family's bad you're just saying
you are the guy that's gonna break the
cycle you're gonna move up a notch
good for you you know it's not it
doesn't mean they're bad people
it doesn't mean you're looking down your
nose at them you're just saying I'm
gonna better myself that's a good thing
and you may catch some flack from family
for this so you better be ready for that
because they well they all seem to have
an opinion you know what I'm talking
about yeah so I personally like the
emotional and relational and spiritual
cleanliness of you being completely
clear of all this stuff even though
you're just renting a little house and I
think that sets you up to make your
financial goals more clearly happen
later that's my personal opinion but if
you're gonna do the deal go back and
make sure grandpa's not gonna be mad
when you sell it make sure you write
yourself a letter that says after three
years we're moving no matter what we
either build a house or we're moving
we're gonna sell the property because
I'm not gonna get stuck in this right
and you got to have real clear
boundaries with Grandpa on the borrower
is slave to the lender because when you
eat dinner with your master you eat
Thanksgiving dinner with your master it
tastes different the fried chicken just
tastes different dude there's no way
around it the fresh tomatoes out of his
garden they just taste different when
you only money and that's how it works
in the real world so I personally I'd
probably move off just to ensure that we
go the other way if this was a more
expensive trailer it'd be a deal killer
for me because they go down in value so
fast but it's a $3,000 when it's a
throwaway
and you might rather start your marriage
in something a little nicer than that
anyway nice little house or nice little
apartment somewhere for about what
you're paying now maybe a little bit
more but you might you might might be a
gift to your new wife you talk to her
about it too and see what she says good
question and I'm honored to have you in
my listening audience sir glad you met
the Lord and I'm glad you met this lady
I think you got a good bright future
good things are going to happen for you
I can tell hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]